I was thinking about this I don't know
what your father was like I've only read
one word that he was gruff and then to
me that doesn't sound very good but I
would imagine having being once you get
to your level right now once you have
Secret Service all the time and once you
have these guys kind of taking care of
you they're almost like the father's
that weren't good to you they worry
about your every move they worry about
your safety they constantly drive you
you almost become infantilized in it got
a fight against it I mean I again I
think that's pretty perceptive that your
therapy really it's paying on inside you
ever done it have you ever done you've
never tried it I've never tried it no I
can't imagine after the election you
didn't say I need someone to talk to
what I did I talked to well no I we did
that we I've done counseling yes so it
wasn't intensive therapy but I've done
counseling yeah you've gone to somewhere
where you feel safe enough yeah so
wasn't a psychotherapist no but it was
an MD no psychologist psychologist
psychologist yeah I would think you
would go to an MD hmm no because this
was this was in the late 90s when there
was lots going on in my life did you
remember yeah and so yeah so we did have
somebody come in and it was more
marriage counseling oh but you never did
individual therapy no so so who do you
talk to after the election I've read a
really sweet moment after this horror of
the night you and your husband laid down
at night you're laying on your back he's
laying on his back and he takes your
hand and holds your hand right yeah
that's it they're gonna make me cry it's
the most we-well gesture what else can
you do yeah he's been a terrific you
know it support not I also have great
friends I have wonderful friends I lost
two friends and my brother this year
then it's the holidays are hard this
year because I miss all three of them so
much and they died in May June and July
so it was like wait who died your
brother died I know my brother died
young in June he's my one of my two
younger brothers yeah my youngest
a really really close friend of mine
died in May what was that a name woman
named Ellen Tauscher she was a
congresswoman from California she was
also the undersecretary for arms control
in the State Department when I was there
a Secretary of State negotiated the new
start agreement with the Russians just
an amazing woman and then my you would
call her and she would talk come visit
me she came and visited me a lot and
then my best friend from sixth grade who
had been fighting breast cancer for ten
years but never let it interfere with
her incredible love and compassion for
all of her friends plus obviously her
wonderful family finally she ran out of
things to help her stay alive and she
died at the end of July so you know I I
have had this age a bit oh my god like
you're watching people do you think
about death not I don't think about it I
think I mean I think about it because as
you just said I'm losing people that I
care a lot about because many others
have died too but those three were
particularly hard are you deeply
religious I am yeah I hope well I have a
I have a deep faith yeah Methodist
that's important to you it is important
to me you believe there's a god and that
we're gonna go somewhere somewhere yeah
I do I believe that and I believe that
it won't happen in my lifetime yours and
what happened for a long time I think
that the we're learning more and more
about what holds the universe together
I mean Dark Matter makes up most of the
universe we really don't quite know what
it is but its energy and if you believe
in see I think I think religious beliefs
and science are compatible unlike those
who reject one or the other and so I
think that energy doesn't die energy
keeps going well that's comforting
you know I got a feeling I'm gonna just
be in the ground but who knows but this
day will be probably this this this
gesture by your husband to just sit and
hold your hand it's an important moment
right because there's nothing to say
after you you have to you work your ass
off your whole life to get to this
presidency
and and and was that the dream when you
were a little girl would that you would
someday be the President of the United
States was it to be a lawyer no when did
that come around when I was in college
and the father asked you this because
what does it mean when you say your
father is gruff my father was a I guess
typical man of his time you know he was
lived through the depression he was a
chief petty officer in the Navy during
World War two
he wasn't the most emotionally literate
person right but he had a good heart he
he was a hard-working man but he didn't
really understand different ways of
communicating so when I say he was gruff
he yelled a lot right right he yelled a
lot and he would get upset about things
and he would knock my brothers around
not me but my brothers mm-hmm and he was
you know just really old-fashioned and
we lived in a neighborhood why are you
afraid of him no I was never afraid of
him no but I mean I did you ever go to
him and say I'm having a hard day no no
way no I mean that was you know again he
was so much like all the other men in
the neighborhood that I grew up in and
the friends fathers that I knew they all
had that kind of depression world war ii
mentality and they all wanted to work
hard they all wanted to be good
providers that's how they define their
lives no they loved sports that's how I
understood how men were as a boy growing
up we know right yeah I I'm supposed to
grow up a kid and make sure I make money
from that's it that's it and then I'm
done but you can also throw the ball
around you know I mean my father you
know we would do you know football pass
routines we would go to the park he I
loved softball he would you know pitch
and and and coach me I mean he he was
just a man of his time and your mother
is more complex Oh My Mind's me of my
mother in the sense that your mother had
a horrible childhood she did her pain
her parents what they gave her a way or
something well she was born to two
teenagers to start with right um and
they were really immature irresponsible
so they had this little girl but they
never really knew what to do with her or
how to take care of her I one story she
told me that I just can't ever forget
she was like three years old and her
father was off working somewhere and her
mother was going to go out and so her
mother gave her a meal coupon they're
living in a tenement in Chicago and told
her that when she got hungry she should
go down the stairs out the door down to
the corner to the little restaurant and
give them the meal ticket and get fed so
you know she would go to school and she
never had any food and in those days
they didn't have like a big cafeteria
you brought what you're gonna eat from
school to school and so my mother was
neglected she was basically abandoned
she had a little sister a few years
younger who was also treated that way so
when my mother was about eight her
parents decided they just didn't want to
take care of her anymore at all or the
little sister so they put her on a train
in Chicago by herself in charge of her
little sister who was like mine I've I
can't and sent her and her little sister
to live with their paternal grandparents
and the paternal grandparents didn't
want them either but took them in
because their son basically said here we
don't want him you take him so my mother
lived there for about four or five years
it was miserable and then she left that
house and she took a job as a
housekeeper and a babysitter she was 13
years old Howard and so she you know I
didn't know any of this when I was a
little girl but how does that affect
your relationship with your mother
it was sense that when you have a woman
great who has gotten nothing right
how does she have anything to give you
you know I'll tell you what was so
remarkable about my mother because I've
read about your mom and my mom was also
depressed right she would you know we
didn't know what that was but you know
she would be really sad some days she
didn't want to get out of bed she was
just so sad and she I don't think a an a
day went by I know a day didn't go by
maybe an hour didn't go by where she
wasn't wondering why she hadn't been
loved why her parents didn't love her
why they sent her away why her
grandparents were so cruel to her yes
but I said to her one time I said I
didn't once I learned about this I said
you know how did you do it I mean how
did you survive and how did you turn out
to be resilient and wanting to be a mom
and wanting to do the best you could for
your kids here's what she said she said
at critical moments somebody was kind to
me hmm and so you know like that when
she didn't have any food in first grade
and finally the teacher would bring
extra food without humiliating her and
she'd say oh you know Dorothy I I just
brought too much food today would you
like my extra sandwich or and and that
teacher did that for the whole year but
what can you get from a mother like that
I would imagine you growing up and you
were a bright student you did well in
everything when I'm talking about your
emotional needs
I can't imagine you a mother taking care
of any of your emotional needs or being
able did she ever say to you what are
you complaining about Hilary I didn't
have anything you've got two parents
you've got a home stop your nonsense she
never said that really she never said
that what she would say instead is short
of that she would say you know we really
want you to have the best life and the
best education and then you can make
whatever decisions you want but why she
was jealous of you no I don't think she
was jealous I think how could she not be
because I think and you know she was a
remarkable person because with all of
this turmoil she never lost her desire
to learn things so she never got to go
to college
this is the final insult so she
graduates from high school because when
she took that job in the other woman's
home she didn't think she get to go to
high school right and so the woman said
to her this is another one of those acts
of kindness would you like to go to high
school and my mother said really would
and and the house she was then living in
and taken care of was one town over and
she said but I want to go to the high
school where all my friends were the
people that she'd gone to school with up
until then so the woman said well if you
get up early and get your chores done
you can go to high school but you'll
have to come right back after school
now that sounds harsh if you're a 13
year old to my mother it was a gift
right so she'd get up at the crack of
dawn she'd get the kids ready whatever
she had to do and then she would run to
high school and then she would run back
afterwards she had she had you know talk
about clothes she had two glasses but
she was like a slave I mean she was like
a she didn't feel that she's you didn't
this I'll tell you what she said to me
it was the first house she'd ever been
in where the husband and the wife loved
each other
treated each other right loved the
children cared about them set standards
for them my mother said I learned how to
be a wife and a mother from living in
that house for years yeah so she gets
out of high school and you know
California had this great higher
education system and she could have gone
for practically nothing her mother her
biological mother contacts her and says
oh I've heard you graduated from high
school I'm remarried would you like to
come Chicago and my new husband and I
will send you to college so for my
mother it was like oh wow maybe my
mother does care about me so she leaves
California she goes to Chicago and they
wouldn't send her to college they wanted
her to keep house for them oh man I mean
you can't I mean it gets worse it gets
worse so but my mother you know it it
emotionally it was devastating to her
but she was smart enough she was really
smart she was smart enough
she and she read psychology like it was
going out of style every book she could
read about how children were formed what
development meant she read so she had an
intellectual not saying in effect I'm
not saying that it did was intellectual
understanding of raising children yes
and and and worked at it and and was a
terrifically supportive loving mother
were you always brilliant in school
because I mean to go to Yale and to go
to would you do your undergrad well yeah
I mean to get into those schools look I
worked hard you know I mean I'm really
hard worker yeah I'm a really hard
worker no you are yeah I am that's why I
wanted you to be president I would have
been actually working hurt right now oh
I know you would have been but so I I
was a hard worker and I was smart enough
you were captain of the whole Patrol so
you know I was captain of all patrols it
was the most horrible thing that ever
happened to me unlike you you got
elected right yeah I think I did I was
appointed and it was a nightmare I got
beaten up by everybody because of that
did you wear the belt the way it went
around your waist and then and then
you'd stand at the corner everybody's in
a very rough neighborhood and I and the
kid to go your captain the hall because
and then it would beat me up to prove
there that they could beat up the police
I just want to get that badge and throw
it down the river was just a nightmare
but when you when you get into a
Wellesley I mean you gotta you've got up
high academics and you have to have high
SATs right did you have your IQ tested
not that I know of I don't know how to
tell you this so when I got to Wellesley
and really I went to Wellesley because I
had a teacher at gone to Wellesley and
she kind of persuaded me I didn't know
what I was going to do and you know I my
mother never went to college my father
went to Penn State on a football
scholarship so what did you know Oh No
kidding
oh yeah Oh football for the Nittany
Lions between 1931 and 1935 this must've
been a tough guy I'm telling you he was
a military guy football guy he played
football and he boxed Oh real oh yeah
you ever seen beat someone up no I never
did see
your brothers they were you know causing
put your mother step in when he was sure
he would just get so mad at them because
my brothers were very mischievous but he
never hit your mother no never
you sure yeah positive 100% positive
yeah I'll go back and check so when you
go to Wellesley that's we get the idea
to be a lawyer well when I got there I
thought I was really out of place
because it seemed to me like everybody
else was smarter and so is it all girls
all girls and the reason I went to a
huge high school a huge co-ed high
school right yeah enormous like 4505
springs yes you know in high school
boyfriend's yes yes serious boyfriend no
no one you ever said I'm in love no you
had not been in love yet no bill was the
first guy you loved no no there no no
there was many before him somebody
before bill that you would have
considered marrying no I would not have
considered me but in love but in love
but I loved him yeah and we never hear
about this guy always just I probably
pissed he didn't a lot of different
people and I liked a lot of them you
were popular I was pretty popular right
yeah I was okay pop right right yeah
yeah boys were not your problem boys
were not my problem but I never I had
not until I met bill met anybody that I
thought I would ever marry you would not
the cheerleader type oh now you were the
studious akha I was the student and
student government you know that kind of
stuff yeah no kidding yeah so you must
have somewhere in the back of your mind
figured hey you know I like I'll tell
you another story so I read the type
that would promise people free lunches
and and a more study hall or you know
great homecoming parties I mean that
kind of thing and so that I remember I
did run I had I think yeah I did run for
president of my high school government
as I remember
did you win no of course not did some
guy who you know and and and it was sort
of for a day because a lot of my you
know boyfriends they said you know come
on we're not gonna liked a girl I mean
what are you doing this for I said well
because you guys I have some ideas where
I want to do okay fine somebody else
wins comes to see me he goes you know I
would really like
if you'd help me oh yeah I said sure
oh you were really nice I was nice I
wish I'd like you know doing things what
can I say listen I was surprised when
even when Obama tapped you to be
Secretary of State
Oh was I had a lie didn't you know why
you know why I thought it was difficult
because you were fully ready to be the
president in the United States right if
I was you would I want to be sitting
with Obama and in the back of my mind
I'm saying I can be doing this I don't I
mean not that secretary no but that's a
difference between running against
somebody who you respect right so he
gets elected he asked me to come see him
he asked me to be Secretary of State and
he basically said look we're in a mess
that's right the economy has gone
totally down
we have problems around the world he
said I need your help
I can't do both I'm gonna focus on the
economy because we're in terrible shape
wasn't that great but I need you to go
travel around and try to restore our
relationships that's an executive and
that's why I was honored to serve with
him because first of all he is secure
right not threatened by you being
Secretary of State at all and also you
know we did run a really close race we
had overlapped in the Senate for a few
years but we ran a really close race and
it was touch-and-go people forget this I
actually got a few more votes and he did
yet he got a few more delegates than I
did and but here's the thing you were
you were ready a senator you had been a
first lady and you weren't the first
lady who said there matey you would the
first lady but I remember Hillary care
yes that really were really into getting
some kind of protection for children
right and of course you were vilified
for that but it's crazy to me you had
all this experience and then this
upstart a new senator but you know there
he had enormous talent it serve your
husband and and and and and the to
abandon the two best orders unbelievable
both of them right and and they they
just had whatever that magical charisma
was it wasn't phony entertainment it was
deep positive security integrity I know
what I can do for this country
give me a chance very adult very dull
but that's a rare gift right it is I
mean you used to get stuff Oh your voice
isn't right you don't know how to speak
properly bla bla bla bla bla
yeah you know and and so you know did
you ever sit there and say to Bill how
the hell are you connecting like this
like when you watch EV I mean it is
quite a remarkable skill it is a truly
remarkable skill in varrock habits yes
but the campaign seems to rely on that
and that's not really i'm looking for a
good executive to run the country
well i think you know look you got to
get both in the same package right
obviously i think both of them were
really good presidents and had to clean
up a lot of messes both of them and and
left the country stronger than when they
found it which should be the criterion
are you friendly with elizabeth warren
at all i'm sure yeah you like her yeah
sure yeah i realize i think you two have
something in common
listen to this okay i'm watching
something with her on TV right right
sitting there with her husband and
elizabeth warren you know people don't
see her humanity they see her as sort of
this just just this i don't know this
senator little guys a plan mm-hmm she's
talking about how do you know what i'm
talking about I did all right she's
talking about how she met her husband
and she says um you know I uh I went up
to him so
this nice guy I asked him out I think he
was her law professor or something and
like it was kind of like really taken
with him and then after a few dates she
turned to him and said will you marry me
now the reason I say I I relate this to
you I think I have this right you are at
Yale at this point you're sitting there
in the library maybe okay great and you
see that Bill Clinton a guy you don't
know right is staring at you
true true story and you go up to him and
say listen pal I see you staring at me
you're not into playing games you're
saying I see you staring at me
so why don't you introduce yourself
right isn't that the most vulnerable
position a woman can put herself on
honestly it could be you know it was
true because I had seen him around
campus right and good-looking man
good-looking man it looked like a Viking
in those days he had lots of reddish
hair with a big reddish beard right and
so a reddish beard a reddish beard yeah
I wouldn't think you'd be attracted to a
guy with that kind of hippie beard
because at that point you're kind of a
Republican right that was my dad's
political affiliation right you got into
it for a while I did anything to please
that yeah well you know you do a little
bit right so this guy's walking around
with a red beard yeah and hippies right
you're wearing the costume of the day
yeah bell-bottoms the holding the whole
thing work sure we all thought we were
revolutionary yep we're all wearing the
same outfit
we're like following Chairman Mao
because we thought we were being
outrageous well we were compared to
where we had come from I guess you know
I mean it what everybody rebels against
the past I guess well I used to wear
that to school every day and someone
said to me a grown man came up to me and
he said you know you all think all you
hippies think you're so cool he goes but
you're all just followers you all wear
the same exact thing true and I went you
know you're right you're right I don't
want to stick out so when you see Bill
you are able to go up to him and say
this yeah I said I said if you're gonna
keep staring at me and I'm gonna keep
staring back we ought at least to know
each other's names I'm Hillary Rodham
you Wow as I met him were you nervous
doing that no mm-hmm oh my god now I
would never have the guts to even walk
up to a woman so the fact that you could
do that but it is a vulnerable position
he could have said to you I'm not
staring at you get lost
yeah he could write he could have been
ashamed at night and then I would have
known right then he wasn't worth the
time and he's brilliant because he's at
Yale Law right right right
and he's not a Rhodes Scholar yet oh no
he was he graduated from Georgetown a
year before I graduated from college and
then he was a Rhodes Scholar at Oxford
and then he came to Yale so I'd been at
Yale for a year how do you get to be a
Rhodes Scholar I mean that sounds like a
very cool thing it's a really cool thing
I think you have to be nominated by your
college or university and then you have
to go through these rigorous interviews
I see and so and and then he asked you
out on a formal date no then so then we
my love a romance yeah okay so so then
it turns out he'd never been there but
we were actually in the same class Oh
why was he going to class because he was
working on a political campaign to elect
somebody to something in Connecticut you
know politics was his first and foremost
love you had to be with a go-getter I
mean you were a hard worker you well
also you know it was like it it was just
sort of magical and an electric magnetic
did you need to be with a guy who was
into politics at that yeah you just
needed to be maybe with another lawyer
no no I did somebody who I thought was
really smart with a good heart I mean
that's what I was looking for and also
had ambition oh I had to have ambition
absolutely by definition if you've
gotten to be a law school you've got
some kind of ambition to do something
right do you get job offers like crazy
when you go to Yale Law School is it
because I know a guy who who went to
Yale Law School he he was a freshman
would start getting yeah you drop it a
lot yeah yeah there's a lot of
recruiting done was your family looking
at you as like a meal ticket in any way
I think you know my father was a big
saver you know my father never had a
credit card right we never had a
mortgage on our house I mean he paid I
don't know 30 thousand dollars for our
house in 1950
or something right so he's saved and
saved and so I don't think he ever
thought that but after he died and my
mother did have you know enough money
from him saved up uh you know we just
naturally all took care of her I'm just
wondering when when you get a kid we
don't yell Law School you go home well
if you need it right you're not kidding
but and I would imagine too but maybe
you two we're thinking hey when I get
out of Yale Law I'm gonna have some
kick-ass job but then you marry bill and
you go off to Arkansas but that's not
how that's not exactly how it unfolded
okay let's get back to the room so
anyway the last day of this class he
shows up in the class and I come for you
apparently right and so we're walking
out and he said where you're going and I
said well I'm going to register for
classes for next year because I'll go to
so we walk you know those are the old
days when you know you actually had to
use pencil and paper to register for
things right and so I stand in line I
get up to the registrar bill and I are
talking our first real conversation and
the Registrar looks at because bill what
are you doing here you registered this
morning and so I knew that this was all
about you know getting to know me right
then we went on about a five-hour date
where we took a walk we went all across
New Haven we got to the New Haven
maybe formally asked um no no we're just
like where you going no this was not
like a forum this was like okay I
finished registering cuz it's hippy days
it's hippy days right so we get to the
Yale art museum and they have a Mark
Rothko exhibit and I said oh I didn't I
I missed that I wish I had seen it
because the museum was closed because it
was on strike right and her part part of
the whole university was on strike as I
remember so bill said why you really
like Rothko I said yeah I really I
really like him I've never seen his
stuff in person but I've seen you know
photographs he goes we'll stay here just
a minute
so he goes off this guy I've just met he
comes back and he has a
gentleman with him he introduces me to
this gentleman he goes this is you know
John the janitor and John the janitor
said he'll let us in if we pick up all
the trash on the lawn oh my god what an
operator pick up the trash yeah and then
we get to go in and see the Rothko's and
then we end up in the sculpture garden
do you know this reminds me of a John
Hughes movie yeah I'm not kidding it was
like the guy takes the girl on the day
and he gets her into the museum because
he knows the janitor after the
after-hours I swear I don't remember the
name of the movie yeah no I know what
you're talking about but I mean here we
are so this is a guy who is a born
people purse he's it totally totally
perfect the janitors in know me at
college
no one knew but I mean bill literally
knew everybody who worked at you know I
just about he loves people he loves and
you know what he says which is so
important he says everybody has a story
and everybody deserves to have their
story told he just some president yeah
that's also another reason I felt it was
a bonus if you're going to be President
I get you and Bill together working as a
team I'm like I get two from one yeah
yeah why not why not why not